Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. To the Mall and the Park, where we love till tis dark, then sparkling champagne puts an end to their rain, it quickly recovers, poor languishing lovers, makes us frolic and gay, and drowns all sorrow. But alas, we relapse again on the morrow. So that, Tom, is Sir George Etheridge's comedy, The Man of Mode, in 1676.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周的独家加更节目、无广告收听体验、抢先收听各系列的特权，以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。去到林荫道和公园，我们在那里相爱直到夜幕降临，随后闪闪发光的香槟为他们的哀伤画上句号，它迅速治愈了那些苦苦相思、备受折磨的情人，让我们变得欢快而开朗，将所有的悲伤淹没。但可惜的是，到了明天，我们又会再次陷入其中。所以，汤姆，这就是乔治·埃瑟里奇爵士于1676年创作的喜剧《时尚中人》。
And as you will know, that is the first mention of sparkling champagne in all literature. And champagne is very much on our minds, isn't it? It is. Both because of where we are and because of when this is going out. So it's Boxing Day, if you're listening to this when it's come out, and the festive season stretches ahead. We have New Year's Eve, Hogmanay approaching. And so we thought it would be fun to look at the history of the drinks
如你所知，那是所有文学作品中首次提到闪闪发光的香槟。香槟确实在我们脑海中挥之不去，不是吗？确实如此。既因为我们现在所在的地方，也因为这期节目的播出时间。所以，如果你是在节目刚上线时收听的话，今天就是节礼日，而整个节日季正呈现在我们眼前。新年夜和苏格兰除夕（Hogmanay）即将到来。因此我们觉得，探讨一下那些
that we particularly associate with the festive period. And Dominic, as you said, we have come to a special location so we are not talking at each other down screens are we we are literally facing each other i'm staring into your gorgeous face it's it's actually tom is a lot he's he's he's not as he appears on screens he's a lot less attractive in the flesh i have to say even more beautiful so we we've come to Berry Brothers, which was set up in 1698, I think originally as a kind of general store and is now... You were going to say a coffee shop until you were told off. That is what the Bodleian told me, but apparently it was a general store.
我们与节日期间紧密联系在一起的饮品的历史，应该会很有趣。多米尼克，正如你所说，我们来到了一个特殊的地方，所以我们不是在屏幕前隔空对话，对吧？我们是字面意义上面对面，我正凝视着你那张英俊的脸。说实话，汤姆这人挺……他在屏幕上和真人不太一样，真人其实没那么有吸引力，我必须得说——实际上更美。所以我们来到了贝瑞兄弟（Berry Brothers），它建于1698年，我记得最初是一家类似杂货铺的店铺，现在……你本来想说它是一家咖啡馆，直到你被纠正了。博德利图书馆（Bodleian）是这么告诉我的，但显然它是一家杂货铺。
And it's in the heart of St. James's Clubland. So, Dominic, it's just opposite my club. Your club. Yeah, which is why I'm here in a suit. But we have a very special guest. And so the reason why when you read that out, you said that I would have read it too, is because both of us have been reading an absolutely brilliant book on the history of alcohol, which is written by Henry Jeffries.
它位于圣詹姆斯俱乐部区的中心地带。所以，多米尼克，它就在我的俱乐部对面。你的俱乐部。是的，这就是为什么我穿着西装来这里。但我们有一位非常特别的嘉宾。所以，当你宣读那段话时，你会说我也会读过，原因在于我们俩都在读一本关于酒精历史的绝对精彩的著作，作者是亨利·杰弗里斯（Henry Jeffries）。
And Henry is with us here in Berry Brothers. In fact, Henry, you suggested this as the location. Yeah, well, it's the perfect place to talk about the history of booze. And your book, Empire of Booze. I'll just read a quick couple of sentences from it. The country with the greatest influence on wine and drink in general wasn't France, Germany, or even Australia. It was Britain. Without the British influence, few of our favourite wines would even be in existence. And Dominic, we're a very patriotic podcast, aren't we?
亨利就和我们一起在贝瑞兄弟这里。事实上，亨利，这个地点是你建议的。是的，好吧，这里是谈论美酒历史的绝佳地点。还有你的书，《美酒帝国》（Empire of Booze）。我从里面随手读两句。对葡萄酒乃至整个酒类影响最大的国家，不是法国、德国，甚至不是澳大利亚。而是英国。如果没有英国的影响，我们最喜爱的许多葡萄酒甚至根本就不会存在。多米尼克，我们是一个非常爱国的播客，对吧？
We're very patriotic. We're the people's podcast. But we're also very much a British podcast. And so it's absolutely brilliant, Henry, that you have given us the excuse to talk about the history of alcohol and focus it very much on Britain. So could just begin, Dominic mentioned champagne as perhaps the kind of paradigmatic drink that people at Christmas use to toast the festive season. In what possible way could champagne be considered a British drink, bearing in mind that champagne is in France? Yes, it's a bit of a leap, isn't it? But in order to keep bubbles in a bottle, you need a very strong bottle,
我们非常爱国。我们是人民的播客。但我们本质上也是一个英国播客。所以，亨利，你给了我们一个借口来探讨酒精的历史，并将其主要聚焦于英国，这真的是太棒了。那么能不能先从——多米尼克提到了香槟，它或许是人们在圣诞节用来为节日干杯的典型饮品。考虑到香槟产自法国，香槟怎么可能被认为是一种英国饮品呢？是的，这跨度确实有点大，对吧？但要在瓶子里留住气泡，你需要一个非常坚固的瓶子，
because the pressure is huge. And bottles previously would have been like a decanter so if you, they would break very easily, they were very fragile. But in 1630 a scientist, a polymath a rogue called Sir Kenan Digby
因为压力巨大。以前的瓶子就像醒酒器一样，如果你……它们非常容易破碎，极其脆弱。但在1630年，一位科学家、多面手、一个名叫肯内尔·迪格比爵士（Sir Kenelm Digby）的流氓
invented or probably invented a strong glass bottle and we don't really need to go into detail about how he did that. We're not a glass-making podcast. We are a podcast that's done the gunpowder plot, however. And so he was the son of one of the conspirators, wasn't he? He was, yeah.
发明了——或者说可能发明了——一个坚固的玻璃瓶。我们其实没必要深入探讨他是怎么做到的。我们又不是一个制造玻璃的播客。不过，我们是一个制作过火药阴谋（gunpowder plot）节目的播客。所以他是其中一个阴谋家的儿子，对吧？他的确是，是的。
His father was a Catholic conspirator. So he was sort of disgraced during the Civil War time. So he had this wonderful career travelling around Europe. I think he was propositioned by marie de medici or so he claimed in his memoirs but he was also a a scientist and used to correspond with galileo and you know all the kind of big night big names at the time and he was a founder member of the royal society and he experimented with glass and one of the things that he he did was come up with a new type of furnace that could make glass much much stronger so he invented so when we think of a bottle which
他的父亲是一名天主教阴谋家。因此他在内战期间遭到了一定程度的失势。所以他度过了精彩的一生，游历欧洲。我记得他曾被玛丽·德·美第奇（Marie de Medici）追求过——他在回忆录里是这么声称的——但他同时也是一名科学家，经常与伽利略以及当时所有的大人物通信。他是皇家学会（Royal Society）的创始成员，他做过玻璃实验。他所做的事情之一，就是设计了一种新型熔炉，能让玻璃变得结实得多。所以他发明了……因此当我们想到瓶子这个概念时，
is something quite strong that can hold wine or whatever you want in it we have sir ken and digby to thank for that and then so he and other scientists at the time were experimenting with making things fizz so if you think of um wine when when it ferments, it fizzes and all the carbon dioxide sort of dissipates. But if you can control that fermentation in a strong bottle and cork it, then the carbon dioxide gets dissolved into the liquid. And then you open it, voila, something very similar to champagne. So before Cam D camden b and he develops this wines were not fizzy wines would have been accidentally fizzy so that would have been kind of spoiled it would have been considered a fault so if your your barrel of champagne which
它是一种能装葡萄酒或任何你想要的东西的相当坚固的容器，我们可得感谢肯内尔·迪格比爵士。然后，他和当时的科学家们开始试验如何让东西产生气泡。如果你想想……嗯，葡萄酒在发酵时会产生气泡，而所有的二氧化碳都会散发出去。但如果你能在坚固的瓶子里控制这种发酵并用软木塞封口，那么二氧化碳就会溶解到液体中。接着当你打开它时，瞧，这就变成了非常类似于香槟的东西。所以在这之前——在肯内尔·迪格比开发出这个之前，葡萄酒并不是起泡酒。葡萄酒只会是意外起泡，那通常会被认为是一种瑕疵。所以如果你的一桶香槟——
would have been a wine at the time so it's a wooden barrel a wooden barrel we would turn up and it might still be fermenting and it might have been shipped when it was very, very cold. It would stop fermenting, and then it might warm up in March, April, and it would start fermenting again. So there would be a slight fizz, what the French call pétillant, but at proper bubbles like champagne, you wouldn't have been able to do that. So the French, if they were listening to it, I mean, obviously we did once have millions of French listeners,
当时它还只是葡萄酒，也就是一个木桶，一个木桶运送到这里时，它可能仍在发酵，而且可能是在非常非常冷的时候运送的。它会停止发酵，然后到了三月、四月气温回升时，又会重新开始发酵。所以会有一点微弱的气泡，法国人称之为 pétillant（微起泡），但像香槟那样真正的气泡，你当时是做不到这一点的。所以法国人如果听到这个——当然，我们曾经拥有过数百万法国听众，
but we've driven them away with our Francophobia. But they would say Dom Perignon, when they invented fizzing champagne. Isn't that their claim? Yes. But you don't believe that's true? It's a complete myth. It was something invented by Moët et Chandon as a marketing tool. He did make champagne.
但我们用恐法症（Francophobia）把他们赶跑了。但他们会说是唐·培利农（Dom Perignon）发明了起泡香槟。难道这不是他们的说法吗？是的。但你不认为那是真的？这纯粹是个神话。那是酩悦香槟（Moët et Chandon）作为营销手段发明出来的。他的确酿造过香槟。
So when is Dom Perignon? He's after Kenan Digby. He is 18th century okay so he's a real johnny come lately he was a bit of a johnny but he would have made champagne and he was very important in the history of champagne he isolated great varieties of chardonnay pinot and made very good wine apparently but he would have not wanted fizz that would have been a fault to him all the stuff about icy stars is a 19th century adventure so the fizz are we responsible for the fizz as well the british
那么唐·培利农是什么时候的人呢？他在肯内尔·迪格比之后。他是18世纪的人。好吧，所以他是个地地道道的后来者。他的确有点像个……但他确实酿造过香槟，而且他在香槟历史上非常重要。他分离出了霞多丽、黑皮诺的葡萄品种，并酿出了据说非常好的酒，但他绝对不会想要气泡，那对关于他来说会是一种瑕疵。所有关于“摘取冰凉星辰”的说法都是19世纪的传奇。所以，这种气泡——难道我们英国人也要为气泡负责吗？
we are responsible for applying scientific rigor to making things fizzy before it would have been a very haphazard event yeah um and in fact over here it was mainly cider makers who were doing it so there were all these early members of the royal over here it was mainly cider makers who were doing it so there were all these early members of the royal society who were west country cider makers i love that i love them by getting kind of trashed on cider in the royal academy exactly it's so unexpected and giving and giving papers to the royal academy about sparkling cider whilst whilst off their heads on 10 cider um so there was a very brief flowering in England of wine style ciders.
我们确实负责将科学严谨性应用到了让饮品产生气泡的过程中。在此之前，那完全是一个碰运气的事。是的，而且事实上在这里，主要是苹果酒酿造商在做这件事。当时皇家学会里有所有这些早期的会员——在这里，主要是苹果酒酿造商在做这件事——他们都是西英格兰的苹果酒酿造商。我太喜欢这个了。我喜欢他们在皇家学会里靠喝苹果酒喝得烂醉如泥，
So this was due to a kind of war with the French. And the idea was that cider would replace imported wine. So it was a very kind of, you know, we don't need the French anymore because we've got cider, but it never really took off. So these kind of proto champagne ciders died out, but the technology then crossed the channel
没错，这太意想不到了，他们一边喝10度苹果酒喝得酩酊大醉，一边向皇家学会提交关于起泡苹果酒的论文。所以英国曾有过一段非常短暂的、葡萄酒风格苹果酒的繁荣期。这主要是因为与法国的一场战争。当时的设想是，用苹果酒来取代进口葡萄酒。所以这是一种非常典型的……你知道的，“我们不再需要法国人了，因为我们有苹果酒”的心态，但它从未真正流行起来。所以这些类似雏形香槟的苹果酒消亡了，但这项技术随后传到了海峡对岸，
and the French started doing it. And then, you know, I hate to say it, but they actually did it better. And they turned it into a process. They turned it into a sort of semi-industrial process. But the British remain kind of obsessed by champagne. I mean, we've always been, what, the largest market for champagne?
法国人开始效仿。然后，你知道的，我很不想承认，但他们实际上做得更好。他们把它变成了一种工艺。他们把它变成了一种半工业化的流程。但英国人对香槟的痴迷却保留了下来。我的意思是，我们一直都是什么？香槟最大的市场吗？
Until very recently, we were the largest export market for champagne. And it was created for british tastes so at one point champagne would have been sweet and it would have been for the russian court who liked everything very very sweet and then with the sort of rise of the middle class in england in the sort of 19th century a taste for these gastronomic champagnes ones that you would have with food um brute dry champagne that was created for the english market and is that in your book i mean you start with champagne don't you as we've started the podcast and um it is sort of symbolic of the general trend because you talk about i mean the argument is that britain affects the booze trade because britain is the great consumer i
直到最近不久，我们一直都是香槟最大的出口市场。而且它是专门为英国人的口味而创造的。曾经有一段时间，香槟是很甜的，那是为了迎合喜欢一切都非常非常甜的俄罗斯宫廷。后来，随着19世纪英国中产阶级的崛起，对这种美食香槟的喜爱——也就是那种可以配餐的香槟、干型香槟（Brut）——是专门为英国市场创造的。这在你的书里写了吗？我的意思是，你是从香槟开始写的，对吧？正如我们开场聊的那样，而且它某种程度上是整体趋势的象征。因为你谈到——我的意思是，你的论点是英国影响了酒类贸易，因为英国是最大的消费者。
guess you have this wonderful line that, you know, a British wine merchant had access to more varieties of wine than the King of France did. Because in France, people just drank locally. They just drank. In fact, the French King would have probably not have had Bordeaux because Bordeaux was on a road that would have taken, it would have taken weeks to get from Bordeaux to Paris.
我想你书中有一句绝妙的话：“一个英国酒商能接触到的葡萄酒品种，比法国国王还要多。”因为在法国，人们只喝本地产的酒。他们只喝……事实上，法国国王当时可能根本喝不到波尔多红酒，因为波尔多位于一条道路上，从波尔多把酒运到巴黎需要……需要花好几周时间。
But from Bordeaux to paris but from bordeaux to london would have taken right taken days so it was um you know and london was the wealthiest city in the western hemisphere you say so so um britain serves as wine merchant to the world and so in a way it's a little bit like sport perhaps that um britain you know the british economy and british global reach enables britain to set standards and to kind of export its tastes around the world so that these drinks i had no idea had been shaped by british taste quite to the degree that they are yeah well these create the paradigms so sort of champagne sparkling wine claret port and they are imitated all over the world just one last question about champagne before we move on you talk in the chapter about champagne before we move on.
但从波尔多运到伦敦却只需要……只需要几天时间。所以它是……你知道的，伦敦是西半球最富有的城市，正如你所说。所以，英国充当了世界的酒商。因此在某种程度上，这有点像体育运动，英国的经济和英国的全球影响力，使得英国能够制定标准，并将其口味出口到世界各地，以至于这些饮品——我完全没想到它们的形态竟然在如此大的程度上是由英国口味塑造的。是的，没错。这些酒确立了典范——比如香槟、起泡酒、波尔多红酒（claret）、波特酒（port），并在全世界被竞相模仿。在我们要继续之前，关于香槟还有最后一个问题。你在关于香槟的那一章里——在我们继续之前。
You talk in the chapter about champagne's prestige, about the status and therefore the high cost level. Is champagne so expensive and so prestigious merely because we think it's prestigious? In other words, is it merely a meaning that we attribute to the drink and therefore its value rather than it being particularly expensive to produce or particularly rare or any of those kinds of things yeah it's a very good question um it is more expensive to produce the the method for making the wine fizzy where you make a wine you put it in a bottle you add sugar you cork it and then you have to leave it for 18 months two years three years so that's a very capital intensive process and then you do a thing where you you open the bottle you let the the yeast out you so there's a sort of expensive industrial process um which requires a huge amount of capital but once these companies are set up then i don't think you know it is a bit more expensive per bottle to make than
你在那一章里谈到了香槟的声望、地位，以及因此带来的高昂成本。香槟之所以如此昂贵、如此享有盛誉，仅仅是因为我们认为它享有盛誉吗？换句话说，这仅仅是我们赋予这种饮品及其价值的一种象征意义，而不是因为它生产起来特别昂贵、特别稀有，或是诸如此类的原因？是的，这是个很好的问题。它的生产成本确实更高。让葡萄酒产生气泡的方法是：酿造葡萄酒，将其装瓶，添加糖分，封上木塞，然后必须放置18个月、两年、三年，所以这是一个资本密集型的过程。接着你还要进行一道工序：打开瓶子，让酵母排出来……所以这其中包含了一个相当昂贵且工业化的流程，需要大量的资金。但一旦这些公司建立起来之后，我不认为……你知道的，每瓶酒的制造成本确实比静止酒要高一些，但也没有高得离谱。所以这很大程度上确实与声望和营销有关。
a still wine but not that much more so it it is then so much about prestige and marketing stuff yeah because henry you see i mean you say you make the general point that um the intrinsic quality of the wine often is less important than the ability to ship it to to britain so you mentioned bordeaux is a kind of classic example and i suppose another um a wine that is particularly associated with the festive period is claret which comes from bordeaux and and this takes us back beyond the 17th century back to the middle ages because you know in the middle ages bordeaux was often directly under english rule so is this this is a process that is reaching right the way back to the middle ages oh right yeah yeah right right back to the middle ages bordeaux though sort of
是的，因为亨利你看——我的意思是，你提出了一个普遍观点，即葡萄酒的内在品质往往不如将其运往英国的能力重要。所以你提到波尔多就是一个典型的例子。我想另一种……特别与节日期间联系在一起的葡萄酒是波尔多红酒（claret），它产自波尔多。这把我们带回了17世纪之前的中世纪，因为你知道，在中世纪波尔多经常直接处于英国统治之下。所以这是一个一直追溯到中世纪的过程吗？哦，对，是的，是的，一直追溯到中世纪。不过，中世纪的波尔多与后来的波尔多非常不同。它的颜色会非常淡，更像是一种颜色很深的桃红葡萄酒（rosé）。所以这就是莎士比亚所说的那些“寡淡的饮品”吗？是的，Claret 源自 clairet，意思是某种……你现在依然能在波尔多买到它。它是一种深色的桃红酒。所以，它曾经就像是一种……劣质酒。你知道的，它被运过来，然后你得尽快把它喝光，因为它经不起存放，会变成醋。没错。大约六个月就会变质。
medieval bordeaux would be very different to bordeaux that came later it would have been very pale in color it would have been more like a very dark rose so these are the kind of what the thin potations that shakespeare talks about yes claret isaret, which means a sort of, you can still buy it in Bordeaux. It's a dark rosé. So, and it would have been, it would have been like a sort of plonk. You know, it would have been shipped over and then you drank it as quickly as possible because it didn't, it would have turned to vinegar. Right. In about six months.
所以波尔多红酒（claret）是在17世纪才变成我们今天所知的这种波尔多红酒的。它变成了一种完全不同的东西。这难道是因为肯内尔·迪格比的瓶子吗？我觉得部分原因与瓶子有关，但它当时是用木桶运输的。所以它可能是在伦敦装瓶的，但大多数时候都是按木桶出售的。当时有一个叫阿尔诺·德·蓬塔（Arnaud de Pontac）的人，
So claret became the claret we know in the 17th century. It became a sort of totally different thing. And is that because of Kellogg Bigby's bottles? I think partly to do with the bottles, but it would have been shipped in cask. So it could have been bottled in London, but most of the time it would have been sold in cask. And there was a chap called Arnaud de Ponta
来自欧比昂酒庄（Chateau Haut-Brion），这是一个非常著名的波尔多酒庄。他创造了一种新型葡萄酒，在伦敦的售价能达到普通葡萄酒的两三倍。它是用成熟度极高的葡萄酿造的，处理得极其小心，只采摘……因为在此之前，所有的葡萄都会被混在一起用来酿造这种桃红酒，而他只挑选最好的黑葡萄来酿制这种深色葡萄酒，在新的橡木桶中陈酿，然后运往伦敦。这就是塞缪尔·皮普斯（Pepys）尝过的那种酒，他说它有一种非常独特的风味。但话说回来，这部分是因为葡萄酒的品质，还是也离不开营销？哦，天哪，当然是。我的意思是，酿造这种酒的成本要高得多，因为他会丢弃劣质葡萄。他只用最好的葡萄来酿造一种与现代波尔多红酒非常相似的酒。
from Chateau Aubri obrien which is a very famous bordeaux chateau and he created this new kind of wine that would sell for two or three times the price of normal wine in in london so it'd be made from very ripe grapes he'd have treated them very very carefully only picked because previously all the grapes would have gone in to make this sort of rose wine and he just picked the the best of black ones to make this very dark wine aged in new barrels be sent over to london and this is what peeps tried when he said it has a very particular taste but again is is this partly it's not just about the quality of the wine is it also about the marketing oh no god yeah yeah i mean it would have a much, much more expensive wine to make because he would have discarded grapes. He would have only used the best ones to make something not dissimilar to modern-day Bordeaux.
但没错，营销至关重要。还有他们在伦敦城内开了一家酒馆。你知道的，这一切都是为了触及伦敦的富裕客户。所以我们是在说，我们所熟知的波尔多红酒（Claret）基本上起源于17世纪、18世纪吗？是的，大概是王政复辟（Restoration）时期伦敦皮普斯的年代。所以这全都是王政复辟时期的伦敦。全都是那种狂热小伙子们到处靠喝香槟和波尔多红酒喝得酩酊大醉的场景。
But yes, it was the marketing. It was also they set up a tavern in the city of London. You know, it would have all been about reaching the rich customers of London. So is it 17th century, are we saying, when Claret, as we know it, basically originated, 17th, 18th century? Yeah, it would have been sort of Restoration London peeps sort of time. So it's all Restoration London. It's all kind of massive lads going around getting drunk on champagne and Claret and stuff.
那会是一个让人恨不得身处其中的美好时代。前提是牙科技术能好一点的话。对，而且你没有在伦敦市中心开一家店——显然那会很糟糕。不过说到波尔多，这是一个很有趣的现象：你有葡萄酒，有城里的商人——是这样的吗？那些实际身处城里的人通常是英国人，或者他们说英语。
It would have been a wonderful time to be alive. If the dentistry was better. Yeah, and you didn't own a shop in the middle of the city of london obviously that would be bad but with wardo it's an interesting one because um you have wine you have the merchants in the city is that right the work the the people actually in the city who are often british or they're english speaking yeah and then you have the producers in the you know in the countryside who are french um now with champagne which we already talked about a lot of the names are german yes so it's the hide six and so on yeah exactly so with bordeaux why is it that it
然后你在乡间有生产商——也就是法国人。现在，对于我们已经聊了很多的香槟来说，许多名字都是德国的，对吧？比如汉凯（Henkell & Co.）等等。所以，对于波尔多来说，为什么它没有走上葡萄牙的老路呢？你知道的，你买一瓶科伯恩（Coburn's）或格雷厄姆（Graham's）之类的波尔多酒——为什么你不从波尔多买一瓶格雷厄姆酒呢？为什么那些商人……因为商人一定是在某个时候失去了对……是的。
didn't then go the way of portugal where you know you buy a bottle of coburn's or graham's or whatever why don't you buy a bottle of graham's from Bordeaux why did the merchants because the merchants must have lost control today at some yes well they they I mean they I wouldn't say they lost control because a lot of them controlled the trade right up until the 1970s you had like Nathaniel Johnston you had the Bartons and stuff but the the names of the Chateau became sort of brand names. So you'd have, you know, if you were a prosperous lawyer in 18th, 19th century Bordeaux, the Medoc, which is the famous bit where most of the wines come from. That's the left bank.
好吧，他们……我的意思是，我不会说他们失去了控制，因为许多人一直控制着贸易，直到20世纪70年代，你还能看到像纳撒尼尔·约翰斯顿（Nathaniel Johnston）、巴顿（Barton）家族等名字。但酒庄的名字逐渐变成了某种品牌名称。所以你会发现，如果你是18、19世纪波尔多的一位富裕律师，梅多克（Medoc）——也就是绝大多数葡萄酒出产的那个著名地区，那是左岸。
Left bank, yeah, just north of the city. And that had been drained by Dutch merchants, Dutch engineers in the 18th century. So it's very flat and sort of gravelly and not very pretty. And you would have all this speculative vine planting by these lawyers with a bit of money. And then they would build these ridiculous fairy tale chateaux as a way of saying, you know, we need a lot. Yeah, it's like the ones on the Loire, but totally bogus.
左岸，对，就在城市以北。那片土地是在18世纪由荷兰商人、荷兰工程师排干水改造出来的。所以那里非常平坦，满是砾石，算不上多漂亮。那些有点闲钱的律师们会在那里进行各种投机性的葡萄种植。然后他们会建造这些荒谬的童话般宏伟的酒庄，以此来炫耀：“我们需要很多……”对，就像卢瓦尔河谷（Loire）的那些城堡一样，但完全是伪造的。
But totally bogus. Almost like the ones you get in China these days. Yeah. And these became brands. So you had, you know, you had, Latour and stuff are older, but like Pichon, Longville, that sort of stuff, the pictures of the Chateau became famous.
但完全是伪造的。几乎就像你现在在中国能看到的那种。是的。而这些都变成了品牌。所以你拥有了——你知道的，拉图（Latour）等酒庄的历史更悠久，但像碧尚男爵（Pichon Longville）这一类的酒庄，酒庄的照片变得家喻户晓。
Whereas in Burgundy, for example, if you look at old bottles here, they'll just say, for Burgundy, they'll just say Bone, you know, just the name of where it comes from. Whereas with the Claret, it's got the name of the Chateau so the chateau when you say old bottles you don't mean the kind of old bottles that tom and i would buy forget to throw out well they've got sort of 19th century bottles here at berry brothers and the bordeaux ones have the name of a specific
而在勃艮第（Burgundy），举个例子，如果你看看这里的旧瓶子，它们只会写着勃艮第，上面只会写着博讷（Beaune），你知道的，仅仅是产地的名字。而波尔多红酒则印有酒庄的名字。所以当你说旧瓶子时，你指的不是我和汤姆会买、然后忘了扔掉的那种旧瓶子吧？好吧，贝瑞兄弟这里藏有一些19世纪的瓶子，波尔多的瓶子上印有特定酒庄的名字，
chateau on right whereas the um the burgundy ones just have the name of where it comes from and then it would have been the merchant would have brought the wine and marketed it so even though the merchants were very powerful in bordeaux and used to do all kinds of weird stuff to the wine so they would ship it in barrel and then they would beef it up with port and brandy and stuff for for london tastes because the english were thought not to have very subtle tastes, it would then be sold by the brand name of the Chateau. So just on the English tastes, since you mentioned that, so with champagne, you said that the English basically dictated the
对吧？而勃艮第的瓶子上面只有产地的名字。然后，酒商会买下这些酒并进行营销。所以尽管波位多尔的酒商非常强大，并且对葡萄酒做过各种古怪的加工——比如他们会用木桶运输葡萄酒，然后为了迎合伦敦人的口味，用波特酒和白兰地给它“加料”，因为当时人们认为英国人的口味不够细腻——但它最终还是会以酒庄的品牌名称售卖。顺便说一下英国人的口味，既然你提到了这一点——所以在香槟方面，你曾说过英国人基本上决定了它的干型程度，这实际上与我们的普遍直觉相当背道而驰，因为我们通常的印象似乎是英国人喜欢非常甜、非常……换句话说，大概人们在18、19世纪看待英国人的眼光，就像我们现在旧世界看待美国人对某种事物的态度一样？
dryness of it, which is actually quite counter to our general instinct, which seems to have been British-liked things, very sweet and very... So, in other words, presumably people looked on the British in the 18th and 19th century, much as we in the old world now look at Americans with regard to that. That's exactly it. They like everything over-flavoured, massively sugary, too strong, and so they've lost all kind of subtlety.
完全是这样。他们喜欢所有味道过重、糖分极高、烈度太大的东西，以至于他们失去了所有的细腻感。
I mean, is that true generally, British tastes, would you say, in the early history of booze? Yes. No, I would say that's entirely true. They used to make sherry and stuff. They would just fill it full of sweet wines and things. And they thought that's what they like in cold climates. But also there were connoisseurs as well. There were people who were – there was a fashion for dry champagne,
我的意思是，波尔多红酒的口味通常也是如此吗，在酒类历史的早期？是的。不，我认为完全是这样。他们以前制作雪利酒之类的东西时，就会往里面狂加甜酒和其他成分。他们认为这就是寒冷气候下人们所喜欢的。但同时也有行家存在。有一些人——当时曾经流行过干型香槟，
which sort of superseded the more robust tastes that other English people were. And Henry, on the topic of fashion, the other fascinating thing that I learned was that the taste for claret has a political dimension. It does. Yes, yes. No, it's, it was a tradition wine would have come from France. And the Stuarts were aligned with the French. And then when they were deposed, you know, the Glorious Revolution, William III and stuff, it became much harder to get hold of Claret.
它某种程度上取代了其他英国人所偏爱的那种更浓烈的口味。亨利，说到时尚，我了解到的另一个令人着迷的事情是，对波尔多红酒的喜爱竟然还有一个政治维度。确实如此。是的，是的。不，这是……传统的葡萄酒来自法国。而斯图亚特王朝（Stuarts）与法国结盟。后来当他们被废黜后——也就是光荣革命、威廉三世（William III）登基等事件之后，想要弄到波尔多红酒就变得困难得多了。
Lots of duty put on Claret. And there's other things like war with the Dutch as well, who shipped a lot of wine from Bordeaux. So people went to Portugal instead, oldest ally, you know, all that kind of stuff for the wine. So people who supported the Hanoverians, you know, the sort of people who came after William III, would have enthusiastically drunk port.
海关对波尔多红酒征收了巨额关税。还有其他因素，比如与荷兰的战争，荷兰人曾将大量波尔多葡萄酒运往英国。因此人们转而选择葡萄牙，即最古老的盟友，你知道的，诸如此类关于葡萄酒的种种。所以那些支持汉诺威王朝（Hanoverians）的人——也就是威廉三世之后掌权的那群人——会热情洋溢地喝波尔多波特酒。
Whereas the people, the Jacobites. King over the water. Yeah, the king over the water, who pined for the Stuart king, would drink claret. And the Scotsots you know that would in particular would um would drink claret as a way of the scottsdale's claret drinkers did you know i didn't do that well they have their old alliance yes of course they do and it was a way of saying you know we we don't believe in the hanoverians we we want the stewards back so
而那些支持者——詹姆斯党人（Jacobites），“水上之王”（King over the water）——是的，那位渴望斯图亚特国王归来的“水上之王”的支持者，则会喝波尔多红酒。苏格兰人，你知道的，尤其是苏格兰人……会喝波尔多红酒，以此来表达……苏格兰人都是波尔多红酒的饮用者，你知道这件事吗？我以前不知道。好吧，他们有他们的“老同盟”（Auld Alliance），对，当然有。这是一种表态的方式，意思是：“我们不相信汉诺威王朝，我们要斯图亚特王朝回来，
we're going to drink we're going to drink claret so so um if you've got a bottle of claret you're a tory uh and if you've got a bottle of port you have then you're a wig and dominic yes ironically yeah you're a huge enthusiast for port aren't you i like you've done two episodes so we did one on yeah the the methu in treaty which just remind just remind us what the Methuen Treaty is. So the Methuen Treaty is, I think, 1703, isn't it, Henry? John Methuen, he goes to Portugal and they negotiate a treaty. And the deal basically is, so this is during, I mean, I think at the time it's the War of the Spanish Succession. I should say, actually, Tom, we are actually drinking port right now.
所以我们要喝——我们要喝波尔多红酒。”所以……如果你有一瓶波尔多红酒，你就是托利党人（Tory）；如果你有一瓶波特酒，那你就是辉格党人（Whig）。多米尼克，是的，讽刺的是，你是个狂热的波特酒爱好者，对吧？我喜欢……你做过两期节目呢。所以我们做过一期关于……梅瑟温条约（Methuen Treaty）。提醒一下，给我们提醒一下什么是梅瑟温条约。所以梅瑟温条约大概是1703年的，对吧，亨利？约翰·梅瑟温（John Methuen）去了葡萄牙，他们谈判达成了一项条约。这项协议的核心基本上是——所以这是在……我的意思是，我记得当时正是西班牙王位继承战争（War of the Spanish Succession）。顺便说一句，汤姆，我们现在其实正在喝波特酒。
Yes. If you're wondering. Very nice Grahams 30-year-old. Yes, courtesy of henry very generous courtesy of graham's so if the if the standard of questioning i was about to say over the slips over the program you'll know why so yes the sport of the spanish succession um constant sort of trade blockages and embargoes and things with the french uh portugal is henry as you said is our oldest ally we did four episodes on portugal And then we did another, we actually done five episodes on Portugal this year, Tom.
对的。如果你在纳闷的话。非常棒的格雷厄姆30年陈酿（Grahams 30-year-old）。是的，多亏了亨利慷慨提供的格雷厄姆酒。所以如果我接下来的提问水平……我正想说，如果节目进行到一半出现失误，你们就知道原因了。所以是的，西班牙王位继承战争期间，与法国人之间存在各种贸易封锁、禁运之类的事情。正如你所说，亨利，葡萄牙是我们最古老的盟友。我们为葡萄牙做过四期节目。然后我们又做了一期——今年我们实际上已经为葡萄牙做了五期节目了，汤姆。
Yeah. But the Matthew and Trudy, I think that, as I remember, the deal was that they would be, the duty would be a third less on Portuguese wines than it would be. And so it massively boosted the Portuguese wine trade. The wine trade, yeah. Exactly. So I love the story of ports because it's one in which history is so obviously uppermost. And so you mentioned the British merchants who settle in northern Portugal. And Dominic Henry, in his book, The Empire of Booze, has this comment.
是的。但梅瑟温条约，我记得当时的内容是：葡萄牙葡萄酒的关税将比其他葡萄酒低三分之一。因此，它极大地推动了葡萄牙的葡萄酒贸易。葡萄酒贸易，没错。完全正确。所以I love the story of ports——我太喜欢波特酒的故事了，因为这是一个历史痕迹显而易见的领域。你提到了那些在葡萄牙北部定居的英国商人。多米尼克，亨利在他的书《美酒帝国》中有这样一段评论：
The British didn't mix with the Portuguese and were mocked for their terrible grasp of the local language which even the portuguese admit is extremely hard to pronounce well tom so you're saying that to make excuses for your own very poor well they have a term for us um bebado english which means english drunk english drunk yeah well it's over he gets english drunk in this podcast there's more uh did you see um this chap john mitan talking of english drunks did you see about him jack mitten yeah yeah i know all about him okay so the prize for like me the prize for rowdiest port drinker goes to a shop shops the squire called john mitten i know him well who drank between four and six bottles for most of his adult life he once set fire to his night shirt in order to cure hiccups he rode a bear it's a standard behavior isn't he yeah he did he rode a bear
“英国人与葡萄牙人不怎么来往，并因其糟糕的当地语言掌握能力而遭到嘲笑，而连葡萄牙人自己也承认这种语言极其难发音。”好吧，汤姆，你是说这在为你自己非常糟糕的……好吧，他们对我们有一个称呼，“bebado english”，意思是“英国醉鬼”。“英国醉鬼”，好吧，在录这期播客时，已经有人喝得像个英国醉鬼了。还有更多……你见过这家伙约翰·米坦（John Mytan）吗？说到英国醉鬼，你见过关于他的事吗？杰克·米坦（Jack Mytan），对，对，我对他的事了如指掌。好吧，获得“最喧闹波特酒饮用者”奖的是一位乡绅，名叫约翰·米坦。我对他很熟悉，他在成年后的大部分时间里，每天都要喝四到六瓶酒。他曾为了治打嗝而点燃了自己的睡衣，他骑着熊——这算是标准行为吧？对，他真的骑过熊。
and he took when he went to either oxford or cambridge he took 2 000 bottles of port with him yeah and he didn't take a degree and he didn't and he left all his wine he drank all his wine so so a role model hero a role a great man and a great representative of shropshire man shropshire better i would say than Charles Darwin Tom who you bought everybody with a few weeks ago um so Henry listen let's talk about port Portuguese wine I learned to my horror from your book was regarded as a bit rustic and a bit rubbish until what the 18th century or even then was it regarded as a little bit down market yeah well I mean the problem was is a lot of the stuff that was coming over to England
当他去牛津或剑桥时，他随身带了2000瓶波特酒。是的，而且他没有拿到学位，他也没有……他喝光了自己所有的酒。所以，这是一个楷模、英雄，一个伟大的人物，也是什罗普郡（Shropshire）男人的杰出代表。我觉得他可比几周前你向大家滔滔不绝讲过的查尔斯·达尔文（Charles Darwin）要强多了，汤姆。所以，亨利，听着，我们来谈谈波特酒。葡萄牙葡萄酒——我从你的书中惊恐地了解到——在18世纪甚至更早之前，一直被认为有点粗俗、有点烂，它曾经被视为那种有点不上档次的酒吗？好吧，我的意思是，问题在于，当时运往英国的许多酒，
would have been quite similar to, it would have been from the Vino Verdi region, but you must have had Vino Verdi, very light, delicious white wine. Yeah. They also make a red wine, which isn't quite so delicious. It's a bit too light for me, Vino Verdi, if I'm completely honest with you.
可能会相当类似于……它们会产自绿酒（Vino Verde）产区，但你一定喝过绿酒，那是一种非常轻盈、美味的白葡萄酒。是的。他们也酿造红酒，但没有那么美味。说实话，如果完全坦白的话，对我来说绿酒有点太淡了。
You're a port drinker, you know? Yeah. A wig. And it would have been transported in goat skins or pig skins or something. And it wasn't, you know, it was a local wine. It shouldn't really have been shipped. And it would arrive in England
你是个波特酒饮用者，你懂的。是的。一个辉格党人。而且这种酒当时是用山羊皮或猪皮之类的容器运输的。它并不是……你知道的，它只是一种地方酒。它本不应该被运输出去。当它运抵英国时，
and it wouldn't be very nice. And sometimes they would beef it up with brandy, which probably made it even worse. So something like what we think of as port is this sort of beautifully smooth, rich, didn't really exist yet um and it was only when they started going up country where it was much much hotter and the grapes were yet much riper
味道往往不怎么好。有时他们会用白兰地给它“加料”，这可能让它变得更糟。所以像我们现在认为的波特酒那种美丽顺滑、醇厚的口感，当时根本还不存在。直到他们开始向内陆进发，那里的气候炎热得多，葡萄也成熟得多，
then they would come back and they would buy the wine from the local growers but it would be a much stronger that's more stable while the duro valleys even if you have a table wine from the duro it's 14 15 you know thick thick wine henry what i also learned from your book was that the, is it the Marquis de Pombo? I think he's a bit of a friend of the show, isn't he? He's a friend of the show. Yeah. So very robust in his approach. He's very robust.
然后他们回来，向当地的种植者购买葡萄酒，酿出的酒就会浓烈得多……那更稳定，杜罗河谷（Duro valley）即使你喝那里的餐酒，也有14、15度呢，浓郁厚重的酒。亨利，我从你的书中还了解到的是——是庞巴尔侯爵（Marquis de Pombal）吗？我觉得他算是节目的老朋友了吧？他是节目的老朋友。是的。所以他行事非常强硬。他非常强硬。
He rebuilt Lisbon after the earthquake. Yeah. So 18th century. Very nice. Yeah. He's kind of the power behind the throne in the mid 18th century. And that he is the person who demarcates the boundaries of the port growing region and that the French didn't do that with their wine regions until the 1930s.
他在里斯本大地震后重建了里斯本。是的。所以那是18世纪。非常了不起。是的。他可以说是18世纪中叶王权背后的实际掌权者。正是他划定了波特酒产区的边界，而法国人在20世纪30年代之前都还没有对他们的葡萄酒产区这样做过。
He also forbade the planting of elderflower bushes because the elderberries would be used to beef up the colour of the wine, which was not good. So you weren't allowed to plant them, pain of death. So a fine political leader. No, he was a great man. Yeah. Very wise.
他还禁止种植接骨木丛，因为接骨木果会被用来给葡萄酒加深颜色，这可不是什么好事。所以你是不准种植它们的，违者处以死刑。真是一位精明的政治领袖。不，他是个伟人。是的。非常明智。
Very sage. So the port lodgers are all still there. They're English names, aren't they? Sandeman's tailors. So Sandeman logo, he wears a Portuguese student's cloak and a Spanish sombrero. Yes. That's sort of the Don, is it? That's the Don, yeah.
非常睿智。所以波特酒酒庄（lodgers）现在依然都在那里。它们都是英国名字，对吧？桑地曼（Sandeman's）、泰勒（Taylor's）。所以桑地曼的标志，是一个穿着葡萄牙学生斗篷、头戴西班牙宽边呢帽的人。对，那就是“唐”（the Don），对吧？那就是“唐”，没错。
The Don. There is a George Sandeman who I met, who is very, very charming, speaks Spanish, English, Portuguese. But the company is now owned by a Portuguese company, so it's not a family business anymore. But are there any of, so those houses, they're what, 18th century, some of those? Yeah. And are they, are there any of them still in the family? Taylor's still has family members. Taylor, Fladgate, Yateman, there are still, are there any of them still in the family? Taylor's still has family members. Taylor, Fladgate, Yateman, there are still family members there.
“唐”。我曾遇到过一位乔治·桑地曼（George Sandeman），他非常非常有魅力，精通西班牙语、英语和葡萄牙语。但这家公司现在由一家葡萄牙公司所有，所以它不再是一个家族企业了。不过其中还有一些——这些酒庄，它们历史有多久？有些是18世纪的吗？是的。而且它们当中，还有哪些依然由家族经营？泰勒（Taylor's）现在仍有家族成员在里面。泰勒、弗拉德盖特、耶特曼（Taylor, Fladgate, Yateman），里面依然有家族成员。
Graham's is now owned by the Symington family, who are considered the Johnny Conn-latelys of the world. They're British. They're British, yeah. They come over in the 19th century. Oh, God. It's a part of the news. But they bought Graham's in 1970,
格雷厄姆（Graham's）现在由西明顿（Symington）家族所有，他们被认为是世上那些“后来者”。他们是英国人。他们是英国人，没错。他们在19世纪来到这里。哦，天哪。这也是新闻的一部分。但他们在1970年买下了格雷厄姆，他们可以说是行业中的一股力量。没错，没错。所以我觉得我们现在应该休息一下，把酒杯斟满，
and they are sort of a force in the industry right right so I think I think we should take a break at this point charge our glasses
然后等我们回来时，我们应该看一看另一种具有经典英国影响的西班牙语系圣诞饮品——也就是雪利酒（sherry）。
and then when we come back we should look at the other kind of classic British influenced Hispanic Christmas drink which is sherry
所以我们稍后将带着雪利酒回归。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、八卦爆料，在我们的问答环节中，我们将带你一窥娱乐幕后，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想收听无广告节目、获取加更剧集以及抢先获得现场演出门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
so we'll be back with sherry I'm Marina Hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
“如果我有世上一千个儿子，我教给他们的第一条人性原则，就是发誓戒绝寡淡的饮品，让他们沉溺于萨克酒（sack）之中。”这是莎士比亚的《亨利四世》戏剧中约翰·福斯塔夫（Sir John Falstaff）的台词。亨利，我们刚才已经提到过，那些寡淡的饮品——莎士比亚当时指的就是来自波尔多的葡萄酒。而福斯塔夫喋喋不休、赞不绝口的那种萨克酒，就是我们现在所说的雪利酒（sherry），对吗？是的，基本上是这样。这简直就像莎士比亚是被市场赞助的一样，不是吗？因为这绝对是他戏剧中提及次数最多的饮品。这是否与——正如我从你的书中了解到的——弗朗西斯·德雷克（Francis Drake）洗劫了加的斯（Cadiz），并顺手带走了数百万桶雪利酒有关？
If I had a thousand sons, the first human principle I would teach them should be to forswear thin potations and to addict themselves to sack that is sir john fullstaff in shakespeare's henry the fourth plays and we've already mentioned henry that thin potations um shakespeare would have been the wines from bordeaux the sack which fullstaff goes on and on and on about is the drink that we call sherry is that right yes largely it's almost like shakespeare was being sponsored by the market isn't it because it's it's easily the most mentioned drink in his in his in his plays does that have something to do with the fact that um again as i learned from your book that francis drake sacked cadiz and as it were and um and took away a million barrels of sherry.
我觉得……那听起来有点夸张。这是一个真实的故事，但我认为它当时就已经是一种非常受欢迎的饮品了，我觉得那场劫掠可能只是让它变得更受欢迎而已。不过我认为，有一段时间，伦敦到处都是被偷来的雪利酒。但“萨克酒”（sack）并不仅仅指雪利酒。萨克酒是葡萄酒的一种泛称。所以你会有来自加那利群岛的加那利萨克酒（canary sack）。
I think that, I mean, that's... That seems a lot. There's a true story, but I think it was already a very popular drink, and I think that probably just made it even more popular. But I think at one point, London was awash with stolen sherry. But sack wouldn't have just been sherry. Sack was a sort of generic term for wine. So you'd have canaryack from the Canary Islands.
所以它基本上只是西班牙的一种烈性甜酒。因此它可能产自各种各样的地方。可以产自赫雷斯（Jerez），也可以产自加那利群岛。但这就是名字的来源，对吧？好吧，雪利酒（Sherry）源自赫雷斯（Jerez）。萨克酒（Sack）可能源自西班牙语中的 sacar，意思是“汲取”，但没有人十分确定这个词到底从何而来。所以人们在莎士比亚的时代喝的其实是雪利酒的祖先。所以我们说的是16世纪末、17世纪初。
So it would have just been a sort of strong, sweet wine from Spain, really. So it could have come from a lot of variety of places. Could be from Jerez, could be from Canary Islands. But that's where the name comes from, isn't it? Well, Sherry comes from Jerez. Sack probably comes from sacar, meaning to draw out in Spanish, but no one is quite sure where the word comes from. So people were drinking an ancestor of sherry in Shakespeare's time. So we're talking the late 16th, early 17th century.
但这是我们所说的雪利酒吗？还不是。它是加强型葡萄酒吗？不是。它当时不是加强型的，而且也很年轻。所以我们今天所知的雪利酒，来自于长时间的陈酿，并在一个叫索雷拉（Solera system）的系统中进行调配。所以你拥有的是一个陈年且品质稳定的产品。当时的那种酒只是一款来自某个特定年份的葡萄酒，可能还会用葡萄干酿造的酒（即风干浆果酿造的酒）进行加甜。所以你之所以能说它是雪利酒，仅仅是因为它产自那个地区。
But is it what we would call sherry? It's not yet. Is it fortified? No. It wouldn't have been fortified and it would have been young as well. So sherry, as we know it, comes from ageing wine for a long time and blending it in a thing called a Solera system. So you have this aged, consistent product. This would have just been wine that would have been from a vintage, would have been sweetened probably with raisined wine, so dried berry wine. So you can say that it's sherry simply because it comes from that region.
这纯粹是基于地理产区。它并不是我们现在心目中的雪利酒。它只是世界那个角落里各种葡萄酒的混合物。那么它是什么时候开始变成我们所认识的雪利酒的呢？大概在18世纪，当他们开始在不同年份之间进行调配时。人们开始——显然这与……我不记得是哪场战争了，但当时有大量的库存就那样堆在赫雷斯，卖不出去。后来当它们终于被卖掉时，人们开始喜欢上了这些陈年老酒。因此，为了……显然供应量是有限的。所以他们开始将新酒与老酒进行调配，渐渐地，这就成了一种系统化的做法。
It's purely based on the region. It's not what we would think of as sherry. It would have been a mixture of various wines from that part of the world. So when does it start to become what we would recognise as sherry? Probably in the 18th century when they start blending between vintages. So people start, apparently it's to do with, I can't remember which war it is, but there are lots of stocks that just
这纯粹是基于产区。它不是我们现在所理解的雪莉酒。它原本是那个地区各种葡萄酒的混合。那么，它是什么时候开始变成我们所认知的雪莉酒的呢？大概在18世纪，当时人们开始在不同的年份之间进行调配。所以人们开始，显然这与某个战争有关，我记不清具体是哪场战争了，但当时在赫雷斯积压了大量库存，
sit there in Jerez and don't get sold. And then when they are sold, people get a taste for these old wines. And so in order to, obviously there's a finite supply. So they start blending the young wines with the old wines and gradually that becomes a systematic thing.
这些酒就放在那里没有售出。后来这些酒终于售出后，人们开始迷恋上这些陈年佳酿。因此，显然存量是有限的。于是他们开始将新酒与陈酒进行调配，渐渐地，这就变成了一种系统化的做法。
It's called a solera, which is barrels. Yeah, it's a pyramid of barrels. A pyramid of barrels is the best way to think about it. Young wine at the top, old wine at the bottom. You take off from the bottom, you add to the top, so that the wine you take off is a mixture of old and young wines. Some of them very, very old. And the people who are doing this are British or Spanish? Or who's doing it?
这叫索内拉法，也就是桶。对，这是一个木桶金字塔。把这想象成一个木桶金字塔是最好的理解方式。顶端是年轻的酒，底端是陈年老酒。你从底部取酒，往顶部添酒，所以你取出的酒是新酒和老酒的混合物。其中有些酒非常非常老。那么，做这件事的人是英国人还是西班牙人？或者到底是谁在做？
And in correspondence to whose tastes? Spanish or British tastes? Well, it wouldn't just be English taste or British taste. It would also be American tastes, French taste, because sherry was sort of, you know, pretty big all over the place. Most of the merchants were actually Spanish spanish or there were some french ones the domic one of the big names was french lustau another one was french most of them there weren't that many english ones apart from there's gonzalez bias and then there's who's i know there were
这又是迎合谁的口味呢？西班牙口味还是英国口味？嗯，这不单单是英国人的口味。这也包括美国人的口味、法国人的口味，因为雪莉酒在当时可以说是到处都很受欢迎。大多数酒商其实是西班牙人，或者也有一些法国人，其中一个大牌叫露托（Lustau），另一个也是法国人，他们大多数人其实没有那么多英国人，除了有冈萨雷斯-比亚斯（Gonzalez Byass），还有谁呢，我记得还有
there were some individuals osborne which is when you see those bulls yes dotted around that's on the spanish landscape but they've been there so long that they'd become hispanophile if you will so they were all sport so the that's the thing is that in in in jerez they went native right in a way that they didn't in portugal in porto so so something that they have in common well i had always imagined before reading your book that the fortification so the adding of i don't know brandy let's say brandy yeah um was because of transport because so i had sort of read somewhere a few years ago oh because of the war of the spanish succession blah blah blah people added they fortified portuguese wine and they invented port for the british and i thought oh what a tremendous fact but it sounds
还有一些散户，比如奥斯本（Osborne）——当你看到那些散布在西班牙风景中的公牛标志时，是的，那就是他们的。但他们在那里呆了太久，以至于如果你愿意的话，他们已经变得比西班牙人还要西班牙人了。所以他们都成了奥斯本。关键在于，在赫雷斯（Jerez），他们融入了当地社会，以一种在葡萄牙波尔图没有发生过的方式。所以——他们有什么共同点呢？嗯，在读你的书之前，我一直以为加烈——也就是加入，我不知道，比如说白兰地，对吧，白兰地，嗯——是为了便于运输。因为我几年前在某个地方看到过，“哦，因为西班牙王位继承战争啦巴拉巴拉，人们加入了，他们加烈了葡萄牙酒，为英国人发明了波特酒。”我当时想：“哇，这真是一个了不起的事实！”但听起来
like from the examples of sherry and port that you give that the fortification is actually not to do with the transport or anything it's to do with that debased vulgar taste vulgar tastes is that is that right yeah i mean it's quite hard to know exactly when and why fortification became routine people say it's to make a you know a product that but then a wine, if it's well-made and strong enough, will travel without fortification. There's no need to fortify. People think, sort of jumping ahead to Madeira, there are letters from English merchants saying,
从你给出的雪莉酒和波特酒的例子来看，加烈实际上跟运输什么的没有关系，而是和那种低俗、庸俗的口味有关？庸俗的口味，是这样吗？对，我的意思是，很难确切知道加烈是什么时候以及为什么变成常规做法的。人们说这是为了制造出一种产品，但实际上，如果一款酒酿造得很好、酒精度足够高，不加烈也能经受运输。根本没有加烈这回事。人们以为——跳到马德拉酒（Madeira）来看——有英国商人的信件说，
send some more of that strong stuff. So apparently, due to various wars, people started distilling wine because they had too much of it. So you had brandy that they didn't really know what to do with. So they started sticking it, beefing up the wine. I have a theory which goes back to a podcast that went out a few weeks ago. Because we did a podcast about roast beef, didn't we, Tom? We did, yes.
多寄点那种烈性的酒来。所以显然，由于各种战争，人们开始蒸馏葡萄酒，因为他们生产的葡萄酒太多了。所以他们有了不知道该怎么处理的白兰地。于是他们开始把白兰地倒进去，以此来加强葡萄酒的酒精度。我有一个理论，这可以追溯到几周前播出的一个播客节目。因为我们做过一期关于烤牛肉的播客，对吧，汤姆？我们做过，是的。
And there was always this sort of sense in the 18th century that English cooking was more robust and more simple. You know, it was kind of… Honest. But it was sort of, you'd have your roast beef, but you'd have very, very strong mustard or horseradish with it, much stronger than the… Much more pungent than the more complicated, sophisticated sauces they had in France or Italy. And I'm wondering whether people wanted very sort of robust, earthy, rich, big drinks. You're saying sherry is John Bull's tipple? Yes, I'm saying if you drink port or sherry now,
在18世纪，人们总是有一种感觉，认为英国烹饪更加粗犷、更加简单。你知道，它有点……朴实。但这也是那种，你会吃着烤牛肉，但会配上非常非常烈的芥末或辣根，比那些……比法国或意大利那些更复杂、更精致的酱汁要刺激得多，辛辣得多。我在想，人们当时是不是就想要那种非常粗犷、质朴、浓郁、带劲的饮料。你是说雪莉酒就是“约翰·牛”式的杯中物？对，我的意思是，如果你现在喝波特酒或雪莉酒，
you can pat yourself on the back and say, Beef and Liberty, Rafa Dr. Johnson, all this sort of stuff, which I do all the time anyway, actually. I know you do. Is that possible? Yeah, there might be something in there. And also you could sort of link it with the way that English people took to Indian food so much,
你可以拍拍自己的胸脯说：“牛肉与自由”，塞缪尔·约翰逊博士（Dr. Johnson），所有这些诸如此类的事情——其实我一直都在这么做。我知道你会这么做。这有可能吗？对，里面或许真有那么点道理。而且你也可以把它和英国人对印度菜的喜爱联系起来，
because it was just, we like big, punchy, spicy flavours. I mean, you say that by the middle of the 19th century, roughly 40% of the wine drunk in Britain is sherry. And is that sherry as we would recognise it now? That would have been not dissimilar to your sort of Harvey's Bristol cream. So in what proportion are they drinking it? I mean... They would have drunk it just your sort of Harvey's Bristol cream. So in what proportion are they drinking it? I mean... They would have drunk it just to sort of neat.
因为很简单，我们就喜欢这种浓郁、带劲、辛辣的风味。我的意思是，你提到到了19世纪中期，英国饮用的葡萄酒中大约有40%是雪莉酒。那么，那时的雪莉酒是我们现在能认出的那种雪莉酒吗？那应该跟你们那种哈维斯里斯托奶油雪莉酒（Harvey's Bristol Cream）差不太多。那么他们是以什么比例在喝呢？我是说……他们当时喝它，就跟……哈维斯里斯托奶油雪莉酒差不多。那么他们是以什么比例在喝呢？我是说……他们当时喝它，就纯粹是……净饮。
They would have had it, you know, like you'd go to someone's house and rather than tea or coffee, you might just be off to a show. Because today, I mean, you kind of have a... Oh, have a sherry, a little cheeky sherry, and then you move on to something else. Tom, do you have a cheeky Harvey's Bristol cream every now and again? No, I have a dry sherry. I have a Fino. A Fino, yeah.
他们喝它呢，你知道的，就像你去某人家里做客，比起茶或咖啡，你可能正准备去看演出。因为现在，我的意思是，你大概会……哦，喝一杯雪莉酒，来上一杯带点俏皮意味的雪莉酒，然后你就会转喝别的。汤姆，你偶尔会来上一杯俏皮的哈维斯里斯托奶油雪莉酒吗？不，我喝干型雪莉酒。我喝菲诺雪莉（Fino）。菲诺雪莉，对。
And what's the one that tastes like Christmas pudding? Pedro Jimenez? Yeah, Pedro Jimenez. Oh, that is... I mean, that's a Patriot's drink, isn't it? I like Pedro Jimenez, but Henry's just laughing
那尝起来像圣诞布丁的是哪一种？佩德罗·希梅内斯（Pedro Ximenez）？对，佩德罗·希梅内斯。哦，那真是……我的意思是，那绝对是爱国者的饮料，对吧？我喜欢佩德罗·希梅内斯，但亨利只是在笑，
and not showing the respect that I think... No, because... Do you like Pedro Jimenez, Henry? Or do you think... I find it quite hard to drink, but in very small doses. Yeah, because in small doses, that's the thing.
并没有表现出我认为应该有的尊重……不，因为……亨利，你喜欢佩德罗·希梅内斯吗？还是你觉得……我觉得它很难下咽，除非分量非常小。对，因为只有小口品尝，这才是关键。
I mean, you know, you might have one. I mean, you had two, but you wouldn't have more than two. But you're saying that in the Victorian period, they're just knocking it back. Bring me another bottle of Pedro Jimenez. It would have had a tiny bit of Pedro Jimenez in it. So it wouldn't be this thick and tricky. It would have been a blended sherry with a little bit of very sweet sherry in it.
我的意思是，你知道的，你可能会喝一杯。我的意思是，你喝了两杯，但你绝不会喝超过两杯。但你的意思是，在维多利亚时期，他们简直是在大口狂饮。再给我来一瓶佩德罗·希梅内斯！里面其实只含有极少量的佩德罗·希梅内斯。所以它不会那么浓稠诡异。那是一种调配雪莉酒，里面只加了一点点非常甜的雪莉酒。
You would have a decanter. And just when people came over, you would offer them a glass of sherry. Imagine Dickens drinking a lot of that. I don't see Dickens as a sherry man. I never thought Dickens was a sherry. He liked a sherry cobbler. So he liked cocktails made from sherry. Sherry cobbler.
你会摆一个醒酒器。每当有人来访时，你就会请他们喝一杯雪莉酒。想象一下狄更斯喝了多少这东西。我不觉得狄更斯是个爱喝雪莉酒的人。我从来不认为狄更斯喜欢雪莉酒。他喜欢“雪莉鞋匠”（Sherry Cobbler）。所以他喜欢用雪莉酒做的鸡尾酒。雪莉鞋匠。
Sherry cobbler. So just on boozing. So we've talked before about William Pitt, the younger, great friend of the rest is history yeah great foe of napoleonic france yeah and the jacobin is a great one for rolling maps up so we were very impressed by him as a three bottle man weren't we talking a man who drank three bottles of wine but the bottles were generally smaller they would be they probably would have been imperial pint bottles so they're like a pint of milk a pint of milk but but stronger
雪莉鞋匠。那么说回酗酒。我们之前聊过小威廉·皮特（William Pitt the younger），他是《历史的其余部分》的挚友——太棒了——是拿破仑法兰西的死敌——是的——雅各宾派的死敌，是个喜欢把地图卷起来的人——所以我们对这个“三瓶男人”印象深刻，对吧，汤姆？一个能喝下三瓶酒的男人，不过当时的瓶子通常比较小，它们可能本来是皇家品脱瓶，所以它们就像一品脱牛奶，一品脱牛奶——但是更烈，
that we know full of alcohol or alcoholic milk right they probably wouldn't have been 20 like normal port they would probably been they may not have been fortified at all so they might have been 15 percent right dry wine and so you know but like having a pint of australian shiraz perhaps so henry points of those also i mean a a contemporary of Pitt's, William Wilberforce, and you say that he has this, he's a massive lad, hanging out with all the lads, all that kind of thing, and then he has this evangelical conversion and decides he's going to go off and abolish slavery.
我们知道那里面全是酒精，或者说是酒精味的牛奶，对吧？它们的酒精度可能不像普通波特酒那样达到20度，它们可能根本没有加烈，所以酒精度可能只有15度左右，对吧？干型葡萄酒，所以你知道的，就像喝了一品脱澳大利亚设拉子（Shiraz）一样。所以亨利指出了这一点——此外，皮特的同代人威廉·威尔伯福斯（William Wilberforce），你说他有这样一段经历，他曾是个放荡不羁的年轻人，和所有小伙子们鬼混，诸如此类，然后他经历了一次宗教福音派的皈依，决定要去废除奴隶制。
And the marker of his kind of this pledge is that he's going to be abstemious. And he writes in his journal, from now on, I'm only going to drink six glasses of wine a day. Yeah, that's brilliant. Very abstemious. It sounds hilarious to us that this is kind of you know this is the sobriety how big is the glass i mean how how abstemious is he being and only having six glasses a day well it's hard to know isn't it but when you look at the glasses when you look at vintage port glasses they're quite little and you think of master and commander and then yes
而他这种承诺的标志就是他要戒酒。他在日记里写道，从今以后，他每天只喝六杯酒。对，太绝了。非常克制。在我们听来这真是荒谬极了，这就是所谓的清心寡欲？那杯子到底有多大？我是说，他每天只喝六杯，这到底算哪门子的克制？嗯，这很难说，对吧？但当你看看那些杯子，当你看看复古的波特酒杯时，它们其实非常小，你会想起电影《怒海争锋》（Master and Commander），然后是的，
toasting and stuff. They would have been quite... So actually, that's quite abstemious, I think, if we assume that he was having little glasses of port. That's quite healthy. And the glasses of sherry that people are having in the Victorian period. So I think of the Victorians as quite abstemious, generally. No, I don't.
各种祝酒什么的。它们其实相当……所以实际上，如果我们假设他喝的是小杯的波特酒，这其实挺克制的，我觉得。这挺健康的。还有维多利亚时期人们喝的雪莉酒杯。所以我觉得维多利亚时期的人们总体上相当克制。不，我不这么认为。
Don't you? No, I think they were having sherry cobblers and blind man's buff. I mean, only if you're Scrooge in your accounting house. No, I think they drank... Buterry cobblers and blind man's buff and all that. I mean, only if you're screwed in your accounting house. No, I think they drank... But if you're off with Mr. Fezziwig. Because they used to drink just small beer. If you lived in London, that would have been rather than water.
你不这么认为吗？不，我觉得他们当时一边喝着雪莉鞋匠鸡尾酒，一边玩着盲人摸福。我的意思是，除非你是你那会计行里的史克鲁奇（Scrooge）。不，我觉得他们喝得……但如果你是跟费齐威格先生（Mr. Fezziwig）在一起的话。因为他们过去只喝小啤酒。如果你住在伦敦，比起水，那可能更是首选。
You'd have had, you know, 3% beer. That would have just been the sort of normal thing. So beer wasn't even thought of as alcoholic. But they're not knocking back the gin like their 18th century breeders. I think there was a lot of gin. Because all those amazing gin palaces you see around London, they were all built by gin companies. Well, we mustn't talk about gin because I think we should save that for an entirely separate episode because it's such a fascinating story.
你大概会喝到那种3%酒精度数的啤酒。那在当时就是很正常的东西。所以啤酒甚至都不被认为含有酒精。但他们可不像18世纪的前辈那样狂灌杜松子酒。我觉得当时杜松子酒也很多。因为伦敦周围所有那些惊人的杜松子酒宫殿，全都是由杜松子酒公司建造的。好吧，我们绝不能谈论杜松子酒，因为我觉得我们应该把这个话题留给一个完全独立的单集，因为这是一个太吸引人的故事了。
But Henry, alcohol that hasn't kind of made it through, that has gone, you know, fallen by the wayside. And I guess the one that you cite as the classic example is masala, which was apparently Nelson's favourite tipple. It was, yeah. But I don't think I've ever drunk. Have you drunk? I'm confused whether that's the same as malmsi. Malmsi is a type of Madeira. It's one made from Malvasia grape. Masala was originally created as a sort of Madeira substitute because Madeira was so popular that people used to make South African Madeira or Cyprus Madeira.
但是，亨利，有没有那种没有流传下来、已经消逝、被时代淘汰的酒精饮品？我想你举出的经典例子就是玛莎拉酒（Marsala），据说这是纳尔逊勋爵最喜欢的杯中物。确实是的。但我想我从来没喝过。你喝过吗？我搞不清这跟马姆塞酒（Malmsey）是不是同一种东西。马姆塞酒是马德拉酒的一种。它是用玛尔瓦西亚（Malvasia）葡萄酿造的。玛莎拉酒最初被创造出来是为了当作马德拉酒的替代品，因为马德拉酒太受欢迎了，以至于人们开始制作南非马德拉酒或塞浦路斯马德拉酒。
And Masala was originally sold as, well, it was sold, there was a brand called Bronte Madeira, which was named after- Which is Nelson's title that he gets given, isn't it? Yeah, exactly. So tell us exactly what Masala wine is and what the link is to Nelson
而玛莎拉酒最初的销售方式是——其实它有一种品牌叫勃朗特马德拉（Bronte Madeira），是以……命名的是纳尔逊被册封的封号，对吧？对，完全正确。所以快给我们讲讲到底什么是玛莎拉酒，它跟纳尔逊有什么联系，
and how and why it hasn't made it through to the present day, really. Well, Masala was a type of wine that apparently dates back to Roman times called, or this is what they say, Vino Perpetuo, everlasting wine. And it would be in these huge barrels called botti, probably terrible Italian pronunciation there. And they would just be topped up. So if you were a farmer,'d have the have this sort of thing and um and it was a very very strong wine that lasted and that's what the english liked and he had a merchant called john woodhouse from liverpool and he came to masala to to trade may have been wine may have been in something else and he tried
以及它究竟是如何以及为什么没有流传到今天的。嗯，玛莎拉酒是一种据称可以追溯到古罗马时期的葡萄酒，人们称之为——或者他们是这么说的——Vino Perpetuo，也就是“永恒之酒”。它会装在被称为“botti”的巨大木桶里，我这意大利语发音可能糟透了。它们会被不断添满。所以如果你是个农夫，你就会有这种东西，而且……这是一种非常非常烈且持久的葡萄酒，这就是英国人喜欢的。当时有个来自利物浦的商人叫约翰·伍德豪斯（John Woodhouse），他来到玛莎拉做生意，可能是为了葡萄酒，也可能是为了别的什么，他尝了尝这种酒，
the wine and thought i can sell this as madeira this is this is the stuff so he started buying it and then he would subject it to a bit of kind of tarting up the english market he'd add a great must you know um to sweeten it so it was more to english tastes and then nelson who was hanging around the bay of naples with lady hamilton getting up to all sorts. And he visited and he tried the wine and became quite good friends with Woodhouse. And he loved the wine and said that it should be supplied by the Royal Navy, supplied to the Royal Navy for officers. So he started buying wine from Woodhouse, what the Royal Navy started buying from Woodhouse. And it became the drink that officers drank in the Navy.
心想：我可以把这当成马德拉酒卖啊，这就是好东西。于是他开始收购这种酒，然后他对它进行了一点“包装修饰”，以迎合英国市场，他加入了大量的浓缩葡萄汁，你知道的，为了把它变甜，这样更合英国人的口味。然后，当时正在那不勒斯湾跟汉密尔顿夫人（Lady Hamilton）鬼混、无所不为的纳尔逊，他来拜访并尝了这种酒，跟伍德豪斯成了挺好的朋友。他非常喜欢这款酒，并表示皇家海军应该采购这款酒，将其作为海军军官的专供酒。于是他开始向伍德豪斯买酒，或者说皇家海军开始向伍德豪斯买酒。它就成了海军军官们在船上喝的饮料。
And it was just a sort of strong Madeira or sherry style sweet wine. And then other English merchants came out. There was Inghams and Whittakers and stuff. And there was this sort of brief golden age, like sort of Dallas or something, but of wine in Palermo in the 19th century. And they had balls.
这只是一种烈性的马德拉或雪莉风格的甜酒。然后其他英国商人也来了。有英格姆（Inghams）、惠特克（Whittakers）之类的人。19世纪的巴勒莫（Palermo）曾有过一段短暂的黄金时代，有点像美剧《达拉斯》那种感觉，只不过是葡萄酒版本的。他们举办舞会，
And it was like the leopard and they all, you know, they had these huge palazzos. And, and if you go to Masala today, there's only one producer left now in Masala on the front, Florio, who was Italian from Calabria,
就像电影《豹》（The Leopard）里那样，他们所有人，你知道的，都拥有巨大的宫殿。而且，如果你今天去玛莎拉，玛莎拉海滨只剩下一家生产商了——弗洛里奥（Florio），他是一个来自卡拉布里亚（Calabria）的意大利人，
but you see the ruined Ingham and Woodhouse. Yeah. And they are massive. Yeah. And it's like two miles of harbour with these ruined essentially masala warehouses. But what went wrong? Why Sherry lasted and Port and Madeira has lasted
但你能看到废弃的英格姆和伍德豪斯公司的遗迹。是的。而且它们规模巨大。是的。那里的海港绵延大约两英里，全都是这些基本上已经荒废的玛莎拉酒仓库。但是哪里出错了呢？为什么雪莉酒能流传下来，波特酒和马德拉酒也流传下来了，
actually, hasn't it? Just about. It was because there was a race to the bottom, so the wines went a bit out of fashion. Whereas Sherry and madeira managed to keep their quality levels up even though the sales were declining um you know harvey's bristol cream you might mock it but it's a it's a pretty solid product whereas in masala they started doing ones that were mixed with eggs or flavored with almonds or vanilla yeah and it became something
其实是这样吧？差不多吧。因为当时出现了一场向底层看齐的恶性竞争，所以这些酒有点过时了。而雪莉酒和马德拉酒设法维持了它们的质量水平，尽管销量在下降——你知道的，哈维斯里斯托奶油雪莉酒，你可能会嘲笑它，但它是一款相当扎实的产品；而在玛莎拉酒方面，他们开始生产那些与鸡蛋混合或带有杏仁或香草风味的酒，对，它变成了一种
that people just used for cooking so there's lots of italian american dishes so so is it possible is anyone making masala of the kind that nelson would have drunk i mean is it possible to experience what nelson drunk it is yes now i was very fortunate enough to stay at a hotel owned by a sort of masala historian who goes around buying up rare casks of masala and he has them all in his cellar and he took me down there and gave me some to try and these would have been a taste of the wines as they would have been before they were you know sweetened up for the british market did it fill you with a zeal for king and country after you'd drunk it um it's it's certainly there was certainly wonderful wines i wouldn't I wouldn't quite say they're the only ones.
人们只用来做菜的东西——所以有很多美式意大利菜。那么，有没有人还在酿造纳尔逊当年喝的那种玛莎拉酒呢？我们是否还有可能体验到纳尔逊喝过的味道？有的，是的。我非常幸运地住过一家酒店，它由一位玛莎拉酒历史学家经营，他四处搜寻并买下稀有的玛莎拉酒桶，把它们全都存放在自己的酒窖里。他把我带下去让我尝了尝，这些酒能让你品尝到它们在为了迎合英国市场而被加甜之前的原汁原味。你喝完之后有没有涌起一股为了国王和国家效忠的热情？嗯……这绝对是美妙绝伦的酒，我不会……我不能完全说它是唯一的。
How are you going to go to sea? So on the issue of old wines, how far back can we drink wine and think that we're drinking what people drank at the time? So in other words, there must be wines around from, I don't know,
你怎么能出海呢？那么关于陈年老酒的问题，我们到底能追溯到多远以前，去饮用那些酒，并认为我们喝的就是当时人们喝的东西？换句话说，肯定有一些来自，我不知道，
mid 19th century or something. If I were to open one now and drink it, could I reasonably say, oh, I don't know, mid-19th century or something. If I were to open one now and drink it, could I reasonably say, oh, I'm drinking what Dickens would have tasted, let's say? Or would it have changed so much in the interim that it wouldn't be remotely what Dickens would have tasted? I mean, the only wine that would last that long, there's a few, but Madeira is the one. And Berry Brothers, I think they still sell a lot of very, very old Madeiras dating back to the 19th century.
19世纪中期或什么的葡萄酒存在。如果我现在打开一瓶喝了，我能合理地说，哦，我不知道，19世纪中期或什么的葡萄酒。如果我现在打开一瓶喝了，我能合理地说，哦，我喝的就是狄更斯当年尝过的味道吗？还是说，在此期间它已经发生了如此巨大的变化，以至于根本算不上狄更斯尝过的味道？我的意思是，唯一能存放那么长时间的酒——虽然有几种，但马德拉酒是其中之一。贝里兄弟（Berry Bros. & Rudd），我想他们现在仍然在销售很多非常非常古老的马德拉酒，可以追溯到19世纪。
God, I'm quite tempted to buy one. I mean, they're not as expensive as you think. So how expensive? You know, sort of £500 a bottle. Oh God, that is expensive. But considering some of them are sort of 150 years old.
天哪，我真想买一瓶。我的意思是，它们没有你想象的那么贵。有多贵？你知道的，大约一瓶500英镑。哦天哪，那确实很贵。但考虑到其中一些酒已经有大约150年的历史了。
But Henry, I should mention at this point that in your book you offer wines that you can buy that are not extortionate, that correspond to how you think various drinks would have tasted. And I've actually bought some of your recommendations. I bought two of your recommendations in the sherry chapter for Sadie, my wife. And so this is going out on Boxing Day. So by this time, dear listeners, we will know whether Sadie enjoyed her present or not.
不过，亨利，我在此必须指出，在你的书中，你推荐了一些你可以买到且价格并不离谱的酒，它们符合你认为各种饮品当年应有的味道。我其实已经买了一些你的推荐。我为了我的妻子萨迪（Sadie），在雪莉酒那一章里买了两款你推荐的酒。所以这期节目播出的时间是节礼日（Boxing Day）。所以到这个时候，亲爱的听众们，我们就会知道萨迪是否喜欢她的礼物了。
So you're saying Lustau. If you buy Lustau sherry. Lustau, old India sherry, old East India sherry, is meant to be a recreation of a sweet style of sherry that would have travelled around the world on East India men. And the thing about sherry, particularly Madeira, is that they were very, very robust. And when they went through the tropics, when it got very hot,
所以你是说露托（Lustau）。如果你买露托雪莉酒。露托老印度雪莉酒（Old India Sherry），据说它是对一种甜型雪莉酒的复刻，这种酒当年曾随着东印度公司的船只环游世界。关于雪莉酒，尤其是马德拉酒，它们的一个特点是非常非常强韧。当它们穿过热带地区、天气变得非常炎热时，
most wines would be you know absolutely ruined but certain types of sherry and in particular madeira actually improved and one of them was one of the sherries was um lost out old india and by and large just before we move on have our tastes if we went back in time if the three of us journeyed back to 1850 or 1750. What fun that would be. What fun that would be indeed. But would the wine or the alcohol generally be much sweeter than we're used to now? Do you think? It would be sweeter and it would be less fresh. Because when we drink wine, we're used to having those wonderful fresh berry flavours like you get with a Sauvignon Blanc or a Pinot Grigio,
大多数酒都会彻底变质，但某些类型的雪莉酒，尤其是马德拉酒，实际上反而得到了改善。其中之一就是……露托老印度雪莉酒。总而言之，在我们在继续之前——如果我们时光倒流，我们三个人回到了1850年或1750年。那该多有趣啊。那确实会非常有趣。但是，当时的葡萄酒或酒精饮料总体上会比我们现在习惯的要甜得多吗？你觉得呢？它会更甜，而且没那么清新。因为当我们现在喝葡萄酒时，我们习惯了那些美妙新鲜的浆果风味，就像你喝长相思（Sauvignon Blanc）或灰皮诺（Pinot Grigio）时体验到的那样，
which almost all owe their flavours the flavors to temperature controlled fermentation so if you can keep the temperature down when when the wine is fermenting you get all those fruit flavors but in the old days you didn't have that so in spain and portugal and stuff it would get very hot when it fermented so you wouldn't get those pure fruit flavours. And people didn't understand quite as well as we do what oxygen does to a wine. So the wines would all be slightly oxidised. Well, not all of them, but your Sherries, Madeiras and stuff. So the wines would be sort of nuttier and less fresh.
这些风味几乎全都归功于温控发酵。因此，如果在葡萄酒发酵时你能保持低温，你就会获得所有这些水果风味。但在过去，人们没有这种技术。所以在西班牙和葡萄牙等地，发酵时温度会变得非常高，所以你无法获得那种纯粹的水果风味。而且人们并不像我们今天这样完全理解氧气对葡萄酒的作用。所以当年的酒都会略微有点氧化。好吧，也不是全部，但你的雪莉酒、马德拉酒之类的会这样。所以当年的酒喝起来会更带坚果味，没那么清新。
So, Henry, one last drink, because we've been mainly talking about kind of festive Christmassy drinks. But of course, we've got New Year's Eve coming up. And the paradigmatic drink, particularly if you're in Scotland, that you drink New Year's Eve is whiskey. Except Dominic is pulling a face. Do people drink whiskey? Do you drink whiskey on New Year's Eve, Henry? Yes. Tom is making this claim and i just know it's true i have always drunk whiskey in new year's eve have you yeah i thought that was a thing you're maybe not the norm well maybe i'm not but it's my custom
那么，亨利，最后一个酒类话题，因为我们一直在谈论节日和圣诞节的饮品。当然，跨年夜马上就要到了。最具代表性的饮品，特别是如果你在苏格兰的话，你在跨年夜喝的酒就是威士忌。不过多米尼克正在做鬼脸。人们真的喝威士忌吗？你在跨年夜喝威士忌吗，亨利？喝的。汤姆在这么说，而我就是知道这是真的。我跨年夜一直都喝威士忌。你喝吗？对。我还以为这是理所当然的呢。你可能不是主流吧？好吧，也许我不是，但这是我的习惯。
half my podcast so i'm going to insist on it so um henry whiskey all the other drinks we've been talking about have come from the Sunkist Mediterranean. Whiskey very much doesn't. Where does it come from? How come it gets made? How does it end up becoming as popular as it has done? Yeah, it's less different to the other ones than it might at first seem. Because all the other ones were created for basically English tastes. And whisky as we know it, until very recently,
这节目有一半是我的，所以我坚持要这样。所以……亨利，威士忌——我们之前谈过所有其他饮品都来自阳光普照的地中海。威士忌绝对不是。它来自哪里？它是怎么被酿造出来的？它是如何变得如此受欢迎的？嗯，它其实并没有你最初想象的那么与众不同。因为所有其他饮品基本上都是为了迎合英国人的口味而创造的。而我们今天所知的威士忌，直到最近，
was the same, was created for English tastes. Not English, not British. No, no, no. The Scots wouldn't be making whisky for an awful long time, but it was something that stayed in Scotland. Most of it would be made illegally. You had these malt whiskies.
也是一样的，它是为了迎合英国人的口味而创造的。不是英国本土，是整个不列颠吗？不，不，不。苏格兰人在很长一段时间里并不会为了出口而酿造威士忌，那是留在苏格兰本土的东西。它们大多是非法酿造的。你会有这些麦芽威士忌。
They would be very different to what we know as whisky today. They'd be very strongly flavoured, but they wouldn't have been aged. So they would have been almost like a sort of very strongly flavored vodka they'd be like a sort of moonshine and they generally stayed in scotland and occasionally english people would go north of the border and they would try them and they would you you have this brilliant description of that in the literature of the georgian and early victorian period it's apparent that drinking whiskey while in scotland was the
它们跟我们今天所知的威士忌截然不同。它们的风味非常浓烈，但没有经过陈酿。所以它们几乎就像某种风味极其浓烈的伏特加，它们就像某种私酿烈酒（moonshine），而且它们通常留在苏格兰。偶尔会有英国人去到边境以北，他们会去尝试这些酒——在格鲁吉亚时期和维多利亚时代早期的文学作品中，你对这一点有极其精彩的描写。很显然，在苏格兰期间喝威士忌，就相当于
modern day equivalent of licking hallucinogenic toads while in the literature of the georgian and early victorian period it's apparent that drinking whiskey while in scotland was the modern day equivalent of licking hallucinogenic toads while in the amazon i i mean how our scottish listeners will react to three englishmen chortling at that i don't know they can't get enough of that i'm gonna be in trouble for this one but um so it was it was not something that really left scot left Scotland or even left the Highlands, these sort of proto-malt whiskeys. Right, because Burns
在亚马逊雨林里舔致幻毒蛙的现代版体验——我的天，我们的苏格兰听众听到三个英国人在那里发出咯咯的笑声会作何感想，我不知道。他们对这种事百听不厌。我这次肯定要惹麻烦了。不过……所以它并不是那种真正离开苏格兰、甚至离开高地本土的东西，这些所谓的原始麦芽威士忌。对，因为彭斯（Burns）
describes lowland whiskey as the most rascally liquor. Which, it was an industrial product. Yeah. And, you know, English people did try them
将低地威士忌描述为“最无赖的烈酒”。这其实是一种工业产品。对，而且，你知道的，英国人确实尝试过它们，
and they, you know, they did come south a bit. But, it was merchants in Glasgow, Aberdeen, Kilmarnock,
它们也确实稍微流传到了南方。但是，格拉斯哥、阿伯丁、基尔马诺克（Kilmarnock）的商人，
like Shivers Brothers, Johnny Walker. So who's Johnny Walker? Is he a bloke? Is he someone real? Johnny Walker of Kilmarnock. He was a shopkeeper, tea merchant. Wow. So not dissimilar to Berry Brothers.
比如芝华士兄弟（Chivas Brothers）、约翰尼·沃克（Johnnie Walker）。那么约翰尼·沃克是谁？他是个普通人吗？他是真人吗？基尔马诺克的约翰尼·沃克。他是个店主，也是茶叶商人。哇。所以跟贝里兄弟差不多。
Right. And so what they would do is they would buy Highland Whiskies, which were the high-quality ones, and they would buy Lowland Whiskies, which were the lighter, not so good quality ones. And they also sold Port, Madeira, rum. So they would have loads of barrels lying around. So they would store it in these barrels. turned this sort of quite you know this colorless liquid which we had a lot of flavor but wasn't
没错。所以他们会怎么做呢？他们会买高地威士忌，那是高质量的；还会买低地威士忌，那是更清淡、质量没那么好的。他们还卖波特酒、马德拉酒、朗姆酒。所以他们的周围会有大量的木桶。于是他们把威士忌存放在这些木桶里，
particularly sophisticated into something sublime and then they would they would create a consistent product which they would market under branding like john walker bells shivers brothers um but south of the border in england they drank brandy they drank cognac um and that's what you would have when you were at your gentleman's club. You'd have a brandy and soda or just a neat brandy. But then there was phylloxera, which was an aphid. Yes, which is always wiping out the vines, isn't it, in Bordeaux and so on. Exactly. Destroyed the vines in cognac.
将这种原本有很多风味、但并不算特别精致的无色液体，变成了某种无与伦比的美酒。然后他们会创造出一种品质稳定的产品，并以诸如约翰·沃克（John Walker）、贝尔（Bell's）、芝华士兄弟等品牌进行营销。但是在边境以南的英格兰，人们喝的是白兰地、干邑，你在绅士俱乐部里喝的就是这个。你会来上一杯白兰地苏打，或者纯白兰地。但随后发生了根瘤蚜虫灾，这是一种蚜虫。是的，这种虫子总是在波尔多等地毁坏葡萄藤，对吧？完全正确。它摧毁了干邑的葡萄藤。
And there was no cognac to be had. So there was a sort of panic in the gentleman's clubs of St. James'. So the sort of canny Scots merchants decided of St. James's. So the sort of canny Scots merchants decided they were going to create blends for the London market. So the Scottish blends would have been, you know, robust, powerful, peaty whiskeys that were often drunk with honey in sort of toddies. Whereas the English, they wanted lighter whiskeys that they can mix with soda for drinking in their gentlemen's clubs. So the Scottish merchants created whiskeys for the London market, which were close in flavour profile to cognac.
结果无干邑可喝了。所以圣詹姆斯区的绅士俱乐部里陷入了一种恐慌。于是，精明的苏格兰商人决定——圣詹姆斯区的绅士俱乐部里陷入了一种恐慌。于是，精明的苏格兰商人决定为伦敦市场创造调配威士忌。所以苏格兰调配威士忌原本是那种强劲、有力、带有泥煤味的威士忌，通常会加蜂蜜做成热托迪酒（toddy）来喝。而英国人呢，他们想要更清淡的威士忌，可以兑苏打水在绅士俱乐部里喝。因此，苏格兰商人为伦敦市场创造了威士忌，其风味特征非常接近干邑。
Crikey. So soda, you'd have whiskey and soda. I mean, people do drink whiskey and soda or brandy and soda, don't they? My grandmother's favourite drink. But soda has completely gone out of fashion, hasn't it? They're trying to bring it back. So they now call them highballs and the bar keeping fraternity are trying to bring them back.
天哪。所以你可以兑苏打水，喝威士忌加苏打水。我的意思是，人们确实喝威士忌加苏打水或白兰地加苏打水，对吧？我祖母最喜欢的饮料。但苏打水已经彻底过时了，不是吗？他们正试图让它回归。所以他们现在管这叫“高球鸡尾酒”（highballs），调酒界正在努力让它们卷土重来。
I mean, Scottish whiskey is seen as kind of the brand leader. It's the champagne of whiskeys. Would that be, I mean, that's my perspective. Yeah,
我的意思是，苏格兰威士忌被视为某种品牌领头羊。它是威士忌中的香槟。这是……我的意思是，这是我的视角。对，
I would say that's, you know, and especially to do with the marketing as well, because the champagne has been so brilliantly marketed and the same with Scottish whiskey. And so it's seen as part of that kind of Celts, Brigadoon,
我会说这就是——特别是这还与营销有关，因为香槟的营销极其出色，苏格兰威士忌也是如此。所以它被视为那种“凯尔特风情”、“布里加顿（Brigadoon）”、
you know, all that kind of stuff, the kind of comedy Scottishness. That sort of Walter Scott. Walter Scott. Mel Gibson. Not Mel Gibson. The kind of stuff that gets flogged on tourist shops in, you know, Prince's Street in Edinburgh.
你知道的，所有这些诸如此类的情调，那种刻意滑稽的苏格兰特色。那种沃尔特·司各特（Walter Scott）式的。沃尔特·司各特。梅尔·吉布森。不是梅尔·吉布森。那种在爱丁堡王子街的旅游纪念品商店里到处兜售的东西。
How does that come about? How does it come to be this kind of moonshine end up coming to be marketed as part of Scotland in the way that it has done? Well, it was just a way of selling it. It was all... It's as simple as that. It's canny advertising. They sold it on Brand Scotland. there's that thing when george the fourth visited and he all got decked out in tartan yeah and it was all stage managed by by
这到底是怎么形成的？这种私酿烈酒最终是如何被营销为苏格兰的一部分并变成今天这个样子的？嗯，这只是一种销售手段。这完全就是……就这么简单。这是精明的广告营销。他们兜售的是“苏格兰品牌”。还记得乔治四世国王访问时，他全身穿戴着格子呢，对吧？这一切都是由
walter scott this sort of you know and this and the sort of the cult of the highland regiments you know being screened and the royal family going to balmoral scottishness was sort of in but what about irish whiskey because the irish are also making lots of whiskey aren't they yes irish whiskey was was different because it was it was generally more robustly flavored and it was very very popular until it was actually more popular than scotch whiskey until the late 19th century so what happens it was it was pushed out well there's various reasons but basically the new blended scotch whiskeys these of light, fruity whiskey and soda whiskeys, just pushed the Irish stuff out. And the Irish stuff was seen as rather old-fashioned. It wasn't as well marketed.
沃尔特·司各特精心策划的，你知道的，还有那种高地团的崇拜——穿着短裙，王室成员去巴尔莫勒尔（Balmoral）——苏格兰风情就这样流行起来了。但是爱尔兰威士忌呢？因为爱尔兰人也酿造大量的威士忌，对吧？是的，爱尔兰威士忌不同，因为它通常风味更浓郁，而且非常非常受欢迎，直到19世纪末，它其实比苏格兰威士忌还要受欢迎。那后来怎么了？它被挤出了市场。嗯，原因有多种，但基本上是因为新型的苏格兰调配威士忌——那种清淡、果香浓郁、可以兑苏打水喝的威士忌——把爱尔兰威士忌给挤出了市场。而且爱尔兰威士忌当时被视为相当老派。它的营销做得不够好。
It wasn't as smooth. This was how it was perceived. But at one point, Dublin was the whiskey capital of the world. There were four huge distilleries. And talking of inferior whiskeys, what's your perspective around American whiskey? Ooh, well, American whiskey is just very different because it's made out of American grains, like corn and rye is not strictly American,
它没有那么顺滑。当时人们就是这么看它的。但曾经有一段时间，都柏林是世界的威士忌之都。那里有四家巨大的蒸馏厂。说到劣质威士忌，你对美国威士忌有什么看法？哦，好吧，美国威士忌非常不同，因为它是用美国谷物酿造的，比如玉米——黑麦虽然严格来说不属于美国，
but it grows very well in America. So I actually quite like American whiskey in a cocktail. So if I'm having a Manhattanhattan or an old-fashioned or something you know a nice bourbon or you wouldn't drink on his own i might yeah well whiskey's my day job so i have to i have to keep oh god you're just keeping in with the big whiskey yeah big bourbon yeah exactly see when we say i'm sure when we turn the microphones off henry will tell us what he really thinks of american drinks well but america has has basically replaced britain now it has the arbitral global drinks taste i guess well is that so is that the process then you know are we into a new phase but in other
但在美国生长得非常好。所以我其实挺喜欢在鸡尾酒里使用美国威士忌的。所以如果我要来上一杯曼哈顿（Manhattan）或者老式鸡尾酒（Old Fashioned）什么的，你知道的，一杯不错的波旁威士忌……你不会单独喝它吗？我可能会吧。好吧，威士忌是我的本职工作，所以我必须得——哦天哪，你这是在拍威士忌巨头们的马屁啊。大波旁威士忌，对吧，完全正确。你看，当我们把麦克风关掉时，我敢肯定亨利会告诉我们他对美国饮料的真正看法。不过，美国现在基本上已经取代了英国，它掌握了全球饮料口味的裁判权，我猜——是这样吗？所以这就是演变过程吗？你知道的，我们进入了一个新阶段吗？换句话说，今天你所谈论的大多数内容，以及你在你的书《酒水帝国》（Empire of Booze）中所谈论的，都是关于法国、意大利、西班牙的生产商为庞大、富裕的英国市场创造产品。并以此来定义产品。现在这种情况也在美国发生吗？还是在中国？或者在中国，是的。所以葡萄酒的生产以及葡萄酒或烈酒的风格正在发生改变，以迎合这些新市场。是的，这是一个好问题。
words so much of what you you've talked about today and what you talk about in your book empire of booze is about french italian spanish producers creating products for this big, rich British market. And that defining the products. Is that now happening with the United States? Or with China? Or with China, yes. So wine being produced and the style of wine or the style of spirits changing to match those new markets. Yeah, that's a good question.
我想在美国，这已经发生了。是的，因为鸡尾酒酒吧，美国的那个问题——我想在美国，这已经发生了。所以我认为，因为鸡尾酒酒吧、美式酒吧等等——所有那些爵士乐时代的鸡尾酒、萨伏伊饭店（Savoy）所有这些东西，全都是美国的。但美国人也改变了葡萄酒的酿造方式，尤其是波导（Bordeaux）的酿造方式。所以，稍微偏离一下话题，有一位非常著名的美国葡萄酒评论家叫罗伯特·帕克（Robert Parker），他喜欢浓郁的葡萄酒。波得的生产商为了迎合他而加重了葡萄酒的口感——或者可能因为气候原因，它们无论如何都在改变——但其中也有……是不是1976年的巴黎审判（Judgment of Paris），当时美国葡萄酒击败了法国葡萄酒，这感觉很棒——完全正确。但我觉得这一切都已经发生了，所以我认为美国的影响力已经在
I think with America, it's already happened. Yeah, because cocktail bars, the American question um i think with america it's already happened so i think because the cocktail bars the american bar and so on so all that sort of you know jazz age cocktails the savoy all that stuff that was all america but also americans did change how wine especially how bordeaux was made so there was slightly going off topic there's a very famous american wine critic called robert parker who liked big wines yeah and the producers in bordeaux beefed up their wines to or perhaps they were changing anyway because of the climate but but there was also that is it the judgment of paris 1976 i think when they american wines beat the french wines and that seems great exactly but i think all that's already happened so i think the american influence is already
走下坡路了，接替它的将是中国。是的，我想在某种意义上确实如此。因为很多威士忌公司都在生产针对中国市场的威士忌。但我不太确定这是否关乎风味，这更多关乎营销和包装，不是吗？我的意思是，是否存在一种类似于“全球英语”的酒精等价物，其独特性往往会被模糊掉，因为只有这样你才能把它卖给所有你能想象到的市场？不，我想你是对的，现在每个人都在酿造威士忌，所以你能买到非常不错的威士忌，它们产自肯特郡、中国台湾、日本、中国大陆，而且大多数威士忌都采用苏格兰的模版，所以它们通常是由苏格兰工程师使用苏格兰的技术酿造的，只不过地点在台湾。
waning and what comes after that is the chinese yeah i think i think in some senses it is because a lot of whiskey companies are making whiskeys aimed at the chinese market but i'm not sure if it's about the flavor it's more about the marketing and the packaging is it i mean is there a kind of glow a kind of alcohol equivalent of global english where the distinctiveness tends to be blurred because that way you can sell it to every conceivable market no i i think you're right and everyone now makes whiskey so you can get very nice whiskey that's made in kent made in taiwan japan made in china and it's all most of it has the scotch template so it will be made often by scottish engineers using and Scottish techniques, but in Taiwan.
所以，亨利，在我们结束之前，如果你能为听众推荐一款能带他们回到17世纪、18世纪或19世纪、并且可以用来欢度新年的饮品，你会推荐他们买什么？哦，好吧，我只是喜欢一杯不错的波特酒，就像我们现在喝的这样。我知道它不是——那么有什么特定品牌吗？我们现在喝的是一款格雷姆（Graham's）30年陈酿，它是在木桶中陈酿的茶色波特酒（tawny port），所以这就是18世纪的味道？这可能是……嗯，我不知道，也许不是，也许更晚一点，也许是19世纪的味道。好吧，19世纪。19世纪的葡萄牙，汤姆。迎接。法多音乐（Fado）。
So, Henry, before we finish, if you could recommend for listeners one drink that would take them back to the 17th or the 18th or the 19th century that they could use to see in the new year, what would you recommend that they get? Oh, well, I just like a nice glass of port like we're having now i know it's not uh so any particular brand well we're drinking a graham's 30 year old at the moment which is aged in wood it's a tawny port it's so this is what the taste of the 18th century this would have been um well i don't know perhaps not perhaps later perhaps taste of the 19th century okay well 19 well. 19th century Portugal, Tom. See in. Fado.
对。迎接政治政变、革命。还有什么比这更有趣的呢？不过，不，但这会在维多利亚时期的客厅里被饮用，对吧？我的意思是，这是……对。在英格兰。
Yeah. See in the political coups, revolutions. Yeah. What could be more fun? But no, but this would be drunk in a Victorian parlour, right? I mean, this is. Yeah. In England.
是的。你可能会一边喝着这个，一边和安东尼·特罗洛普（Anthony Trollope）聊天。然后玩盲人摸福。还有剑桥公爵的情妇斯基特斯（Skittles），以及她那紧身骑马装，还有戈登将军。还有什么比这更棒的新年梦幻组合吗？这是我梦寐以求的新年组合。
Yeah. You could be drinking this and chatting to Anthony Trollope. And then playing blind man's buff. Skittles, the mistress of the Duke of Cambridge. And her skin-tight riding habit. And General Gordon. What could be more fun than that? That's my dream New Year combination.
好的。那么，亨利，非常感谢。你的书《酒水帝国》（Empire of Booze）真的非常非常精彩。如果你对饮品、历史、或是历史中的饮品有任何兴趣，这本书绝对不容错过。你明年还有一本新书要出版，对吧？是关于……在寒冷气候下的葡萄藤（Vines in a Cold Climate），也就是关于英国葡萄酒的。我的第一份工作就是在英国的一家酒庄，所以我绝对会买一本。我们祝大家新年快乐，再见。谢谢，再见。
Okay. Well, Henry, thanks so much. Your book, Empire of Booze, is really, really brilliant. If you have any interest in drink or history or drink in history absolutely unmissable and you've got a new book coming out next year is that right on um uh vines in a cold climate which is about english wine and so that was my first ever job was in an english winery so i shall definitely be buying that um and we wish you all a very happy new year bye-bye thank you bye-bye
感谢收听《历史的其余部分》（The Rest is History）。想要获取专属番外、提前收听、无广告体验以及加入我们的聊天社区，请前往 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、精彩评论和各种八卦猛料。
thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad free listening and access to our chat community please sign up up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip.
在我们的问答环节中，我们将为您揭开娱乐产业的面纱，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果您想要无广告收听的话——本期节目暂时还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何一句话即可留下评论。
And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想享受无广告收听。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。